ابو محمد المقدسي هو اسمه عصام محمد طاهر
الحافي برجاوي
محمد ولد في قريه برقع تابعه لمدينه نابلس
سنه 1959 و اليها جاءت نسبتها بالبرقاوي
ورغم ان المقدسي عاده ما يضع نسبه العتيبي
الا انه هناك من قال ان نسبته بالبرقاوي
جاءت بالنسبه سهل للقريه الفلسطينيه لا
الى برج عتيبه فهو من الرقه ترك المقدسي
فلسطين بعد ثلاث او اربع سنوات من ولادته
وغادر مع عائلته الى الكويت واكمل فيها
دراسه الثانويه وهناك خالته المقدسي مراحل
مختلفه في البدايه انخرط في جماعه محمد
السرور مؤسس التيار السروري القطبي وكان
احد سلامه الذات ثم فاصله منها ووصف من
قبلهم
والمتمرد بعد انكارها عليه ذهابه لجماعه
جهيمان ودراستها عندهم
بعدين بدا يظهر عليه تاثره بهم اللي
انعكاس في انكار على جماعه محمد سرور عدم
تحريمهم الالتحاق بالجيش والشرطه والجامعه
وبعد حادثه اقتحام الحرم التزم المقدسي في
دروس جماعه جهيمان وقال لقد تعلقت بهم
واحببتهم وهذا كان بعد حادثه الحرم وهم
الذين بداوا يؤثرون عليه في الخروج من
الجامعه وفي قضيه تحريم الالتحاق بالجيش
والشرطه في نفس الوقت التصق ابو محمد
المقدسي بسيد عيد يوسف الديب وهو زعيم
التنظيم الخاص لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين في
مدينه شبرا الخيمه عاصر حسن البنا وسجن مع
سيد قطب اعتقل مرتين الاولى سنه 1954
وكانت لمده عشر سنوات ثم اعيد اعتقاله سنه
1965 قبل ان يعارض سيد عيد الى الكويت سنه
واصبح اماما لاحد وخ لاحد الجوامع هناك
يقول ابو محمد المقدسي سمعت اكثر الظلال
منه من كثره الجلسات التي جلستها في بيته
وحقيقه في تلك المرحله كنت استفيد فكنت
اسمع من عيد واعجب بانه كان قريبا بل سيقا
بسيد قطب فكنت احب ان اسمع من هذا الشخص
المعني تماما بالظلال وبسيد وشرح كتب سيد
لكنه بعدما طلب منه السيد عيد ضروره
الالتزام التنظيمي معه واعطاء الدروس
لمجموعته ومغادره جماعه جمال رفض وبقي مع
جماعه جيمانا قبل ان يغادر الى البصره
ليكمل دراسته الجامعيه الا انه قطعها بعد
ثلاث سنوات ومن الموصل جاء المقدس الى
المدينه المنوره لدراسه العلوم الشرعيه في
الجامعه الاسلاميه لكنه لم يلتحق بالجامعه
او باي معهد علم شرعي في المدينه المقدسي
تكفير الجيش والشرطه والانظمه والبرلمانات
وكفرت الديمقراطيه وفناد كل افكار حين في
كتابه مله ابراهيم ثم بعدها كتب رساله
اعداد القاده الفوارس بهجم فساد المدارس
وبحسب فرحت بها جماعه جهيمان قبل ان يبدا
الخلاف بينهما بسبب كتاب الله ابراهيم بعد
المدينه المنوره بدات محطته في مدينه
بيشاور التي تتكررت زيارته اليها ومنها
الى افغانستان التقى مرارا بعمر عبد
الرحمن الزعيم الروح الجماعه الاسلاميه
بمصر وبابي عبيده البشير القائد العسكري
لتنظيم القاعده ونائبه ابو محمد المصري
وبايمان الظواهر وسيد امام احد المرجعيات
الجهاديه في معسكرات القاعده كلف ابو مصعب
الزرقاوي ابو محمد المقدسي باعطاء الدروس
وتقديم دورات خاصه لتنظيم القاعده في
معسكر جهاد فمن هو المقدسي او عصام برجاوي
وما حكايته مع جهيمان ومحمد سرور وجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وتنظيم القاعده وهل يعد
حق المؤسسا للسلفيه الجهاديه
انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعه
نستضيف معانا احد الشهود وهو الكاتب
السعودي في صحيفه الوطن استاذ محمد
الدوسري حياك الله السري
ابغى ابدا بسؤالك متى اول مره سمعت فيها
باسم ابو محمد المقدسي
في عام 87
في الكويت
كان في الكويت
في 87 كانت بدايات خروج كثير من من
اتهم او كان من ضمن جماعه
اهل الحديث اللي يسمونه مع
الحديثين انا ذاك الحركه اللي كانت موجوده
في المدينه في مكه وفي الرياض في حركه
جهيمان اللي قضى عليها في الحرم في 1400
بعضهم ما دخل الحرم قبض عليهم خارج الحرم
وقضوا في السجن سنوات كان عام 87 هو سنه
خروج كثير من من
الموجودين مع جهيمان
انا ذاك حتى خلال السجن كان البقايا بقايا
جماعه جهيمان موجود في الكويت موجوده في
الكويت
كانت موجوده لازال موجودين لهم بيت معروف
في مدينه الصباحيه موجود
في 87
بقايا جهيمان وبقايا اللي كانوا خرجوا من
السجن كان يعني عملوا مثل يعني
شقه فيها مكتبه
في ذاك الوقت
تعرفت على ابو محمد هذا بدايه معرفه
محمد هل قبل عام 87 في السعوديه هل سمعتم
بابو محمد المقدسي
بدايه انتشار كتاب مله ابراهيم
ومن اخطر يعني الكتب في العصر الحديث
بالتاثير في ذكر الشباب
وهذا الكتاب يعني لانه استعمل فيه وهذا
ذكاء المقدسي ايه جميع الادوات اللي همم
يستعملها علماء البلد اللي هي جميع كتب
ائمه
وهو الشخص الوحيد اللي استطاع يعني ان
يعني يؤثر يعني جمع الفكر القطبي
ممكن يكون تشكيله من الفكر القطبي سيد قطب
ادخله من ضمن يعني نصوص ائمه التعاون
الجديد
بعض الاخوه لا يعرف او بعض يعني بعض المحل
حتى بعض الرسائل الدكتوره لا يعلم لان نحن
عاصرنا هذا كثير من الشباب ذهبوا للجهاد
في انا ذاك
يعني تبنوا فكره تكفير بسبب ليله ابراهيم
هي يمكن ما تتجاوز 70 الصفحه هذه صدمتكم
هذه الرساله كشباب في السعوديه انه تكثير
لا ما صدمتني
[موسيقى]
وعزز الفكر الشباب
تقوي يعني هناك في كان هناك نزاع بين
الشباب في توجههم ونزوعهم الى همم يعني
عدم الرضا عن ما تعمل الحكومات خصوصا في
مساء القضايا يعني قضايا مشهور للقضايا
قضايا مثل الامريكان كان مشهوره حاكميه
الحكم غير ما انزل الله
وموقف بعض العلماء السعوديه وغيرهم من
وقوفهم مع مع الدول فهذه النزئه وجدوها في
كتاب مله ابراهيم
اعطيتهم قوه ودافعيه بحيث انهم يخرجون من
منطقه العمره
في السعوديه قبل ما يعني تلتقي بابو محمد
المقدسي من حيث رسائله هل هناك رسائل اخرى
في هذه الوقت تجاملت معامله ابراهيم
انك رجل جمع
يعني جميع
اصول التكفير اللي ممكن يستخدمه لم
يعني كان هناك القطبيين موجودين ممثلين
يعني ممثلين تاثير قوي موجودين في الرياض
موجودين في كل المحل وكانوا موجودين في
يعني في الكويت منهم السيد عيد وكذلك هنا
في السعوديه
يعني اعرف اسماء بس مش مشهورين
واحد اسمه عادل السيد
[موسيقى]
طبعا ما احب اذكر اسم لان تتعلق باشخاص
انا موجودين لكن موجودين في الرياض لو
تاثير وكانوا يعني للاسف كانوا طلبه عند
الشيخ ابن جبرين الشيخ عبد العزيز بن باز
كان موجودين لكن كان يحملون هذا
طب بالنسبه للرسائل ابو محمد المقدسي قلت
لي في انه اول رساله مله ابراهيم
في صحيفه الوطن 2018 انك كنت مرافق له منذ
اللحظه الاولى اللي دخل فيها للمملكه همم
لو تحدثنا عن هذا اللقاء
كان في عام
92 هذا اللقاء الاول
يعني شقيقات
وكذلك يعني وجود ال همم
نزعت فك اهل الحديث
فتعرفت على ابو محمد
همم يمكن ما هو بلقاء بلقاء يمكن همم
50 يمكن اذا قابله كثير يعني قبلته بشكل
متكرر
همم قبل همم
طبعا هو كان
فيما بعد ذكر اهلي هو بدجاج قبل 87 جهه
وزاره السعوديه بس ما قابلتها وزاره
السعوديه هنا
وذهب الى القصيم وراح الى مكه والمدينه
وزاره كثير من بقايا الاخوان الموجودين في
البر هنا موجودين في نجد واعرف انه شخصيا
وقابل احد الاخوان اللي ذكره قبل ما يكتب
ابراهيم في مقدمه ابراهيم ذكر النقابه احد
همم الاخوان من طاع الله اللي هم كان مع
الملك عبد العزيز
كان موجود
[موسيقى]
هذا
طبعا كان من الناصريين عن الملك عبد
العزيز
فتذكر في المقدمه
هذه مقابله انا ما كنت موجود فيها هو ذكر
لكن فيما بعد المقابله لتذكرين اللي في
دبي هو كان في باكستان
وجاء عن طريق من باكستان الى من بشاور الى
الى دبي في دبي انا قابلته انا بعض
الاخوان ذهب ذهبنا الى دبي وقابلنا في 92
وجلست ذهبنا الى
[__] كان موجود هنا كان بعد ما طرد من هنا
من السعوديه
لكنه يعني يصنف لما المتشدد صنف كان شديد
جدا يعني حتى الاخوان ما يتحملون الاخوان
المسلمين يعني ليس ليس لديه الانفتاح
الاخوان المسلمين
[موسيقى]
صار حديث ثم رجعنا للسعوديه
جلسنا يوم في الاحسان
الوالدتي في الاحسن ثلاث سنين
رياضه
في السجن وبعضهم كان بره انا كنت واحد
منهم كان عندي شقه في الدرعيه والغريب منه
درسنا في الدرعيه ثلاث ايام ايه ههه ولا
المغرب الاشياء كانوا كنت مستعجل شقه يعني
بالدرعيه
وذهبنا المكتبات واشار كتب ثم ذهبنا الى
مكه
والمدينه ثم ذا من بعض الاخوان ثم رجع رجع
الكويت
يعني الغريب انك خرج من الكويتي وانا ما
ادري بالجوازات مختلفه يعني
اسماء مختلفه
[موسيقى]
وذكر لك
كويتيه لاني شفت الجواز مع كويتي دخل
السعوديه وطلع وبعد بعدها بعد هذا الامر
انا كنت يعني انا تعبت عن
سمعت انه دخل ايضا جواز اخر السعوديه
وجاني اتصال سبحان الله جاني اتصال هذا
بعد دبي يعني اتصال في كل يوم ما كان في
جوالات ولكن
سبحان الله
رفعت التليفون وهذا ابو محمد يكلمني يقول
انا في الدمام
معه واحد كويتي وضابط في الجيش والغريب
انه يكفر
الجيش الشرطه
وحتى انا سالتك طيب كيف تكفي الشرطه وهذا
قال هذا يعني
مثل جنود فرعون يعني
تخفيض الايام كانت رائد هذا الكلام ايضا
بعد حادثه الدمام
في جامع ذكر لي في في جامع ابن خلدون
فجيتها هنا
وسلمت عليك وايضا
يعني
تجينا الرياض هنا وذهبنا الى بعض الاخوان
في القصيم ورحنا مكه ورجعنا لكنه ورحنا
بعض وبقايا الاخوان في البر هنا
ثم رجع رجع بالسياره
ببقايا الاخوان كل اللي كان يحاول يحتك
بكيرات اسلاميه لو ما يحاول يحتاج لان كان
حريق كان حريز جدا هو مؤمن من الناحيه
انسانيه رجل خلوق جدا يعني عنده اخلاق
عاليه جدا حتى يعني يحرجك اذا جلستي معه
من من حسن الاخلاق يعني
يحتك يعني
يخشى من احد يعرفه
كان يخاف ان احد يعرف طيب هو لما المجال
ما كان موجود فكان ما احد يعرف شكله اصلا
يعرف اسمه حتى اذكر من جلسه في المدينه في
المكتبات
وناس تبحث عنه لكن ما يعرفهم انه ما بعد
قالوا احنا كنا نبحث عن المقدسي وكان
موجود كنا موجودين في هذا المكتبات كان
المكتبات محيطه مثلا
ما اعرفه ورحنا الجامعه الاسلاميه
على ذكرك الجبهه الاسلاميه يا استاذ محمد
كان هناك من ذكر بان ابو محمد المقدسي
ساعه ان يجي يكمل دراسه الجامعه الاردنيه
يعني توجه اخرى لكن الرجل ذكي ذكي يعني
لك اذا كان خارق يعني
ايش كان غرض زياراتها ما بين السعوديه
والكويت باكستان افغانستان في هذه الفتره
في
باكستان كامل
يلقي دروس عن ليله ابراهيم سمعتها منه
وكان هناك معهد يعني عملها بن لادن وهو
وهو
كان يلقي الدروس فيه
هذا كلام
التسعينات في 92 93 بعدها ما ادري عنه
بعدها سمعت انه بعد هو رجع مره ثانيه
لكن انا في الفتره اللي انا كنت يعني كنت
اقابله
في الكويت ثم خرج من الكويت ثم بعد ذلك
كان حتى بعد خروجه من الكويت
اصلا ممنوع من الدخول الكويت فكان يدخل
ويخرج بجوازات مزوره كويتيه مش اردنيه
فكان ياتي للكويت ثم يدخل السعوديه
الاسباب هذه اللي كنت اعرفها للعمره يعني
فقط وزياره المكتبات يعني ما كان ما كان
يعني همم حريص على زياره احد المشايخ هنا
لان ما احد اصلا ما احد لو علموا ان هو
اصلا ما احد يستقبله لان كان يعتبرون ان
فعلا يعني كان سبب من اسباب يعني همم
انحراف كتير
كتاب كتاب ابراهيم عرضه على الشيخ ابو بكر
الجزائري
هل كان يحرص مثلا
زيارات المتكرره انه همم
يروج لي همم
كان في النقاش حاد جدا يعني حاد حاد جدا
في تبني
خصوص ال همم فكره الولاء والبراء والحاكم
تكفير الحكام
وتظليل المشايخ
يعني هو يقول انه كان يتنقل في الباديه
بالمخيمات الناس اللي تسكن هناك في
البوادي ويعني ويقول ان وجد ان رسائله
منتشره بينهم فوجدوا
دي كانوا بقايا بقايا جهيمان اييه موجودين
كان موجودين في
نواحي القسيم موجودين يعني هذا اللي يكون
تعرفهم البقايا الموجوده في القصيم
وتاثر بهم شباب هنا في الرياض
وكان لما يزورهم كانوا يعزز الفكر لكن ما
ما اكيد يعني
حمل لواء مله ابراهيم في ذكر فتره من
الثمانينات من 88 حتى 98 اللي انا الفتره
اللي كنت انا متواجد فيها حمله يعني
الشبيبه الموجوده
وكان من ضمن هو مجيء
المقدسي كان مؤثر جدا يعني وجوده يعني
يجتمع يعمل همم
هذا الكلام ما احد يعلم عنه طبعا احنا كنا
حاضرين
كان موجودين واجتمعون كثير جدا
ابراهيم هل لما ننتشر في اوساط الشباب في
السعوديه هل كان يعرف باسلام من هو يعني
عصام برجاوي
[موسيقى]
وانه موجود في الكويت
يعني هذه معلومه كانت منتشره
لكن كان هذا كان هذا الكتاب يحارب من جميع
المشايخ وين كان يتبعها الرسائل
[موسيقى]
يعني
كمعلومه لكن سمعت انه كان
ما عندهم مشكله
لكن مثل الكواشف الجليه مثلا في كفر
الدوله السعوديه طبعا الباكستان
طبعا تصوير سهل لكن انت تبين بدايه طباعه
يعني يصفف في الكويت
لكن تطورنا بعض في البرلمان
كانت موجوده في البيت عند الاخوان
بالكراتين موجوده
في ال 79
ورايتها في 87 كراتين جميع الرسائل السن
على نفسه
انه تنقل بكثره
فكان بعض الاخوه ياخذه ويدخلها هنا
السعوديه
لانها يعني الفكر اللي كانت تحمله كان
الشباب اصلا
تعدوا فوق كان يقف بس فقط عند نقض البيعه
للدوله
تعدوا
الفكر
ابو محمد
في تكفير الدول في تكفير الدوله السعوديه
[موسيقى]
يقول لنشر بين الشباب وهو اللي جعلها
المستشار كانت كان ذيك الايام من الصعب
جدا الكلام يعني مثلا على الدوله السعوديه
مثلا بنقض البيعه او ان الدوله غير شرعيه
هو اللي نشر فكره ان الدوله غير شرعيه وان
اصلا غير اسلاميه ودوله كامله هو اللي نشر
هذا الفكر
الدول كلها لكن تخسيس الدوله السعوديه
هو اللي بسبب من ليله ابراهيم بسبب الكاشف
الجليه هو اللي تزعم هذا الفكر
عبد اللطيف الدرباس اللي هو كان رفيق
جهيمان وصديق او اللي كان يهرب رسائل وفي
ايضا صديقه جابر جلاها من الكويت
[موسيقى]
ابو هزاع كان متزوج اكثر
زوجه فلسطينيه زوجه مفروسه
عبد اللطيف الدرباس كان زوجته مصريه الاصل
قديمه
ثم بعدين تزوج زوجه فلسطينيه اللي هي اخت
لكن
[موسيقى]
هذه العلاقه النسب غير علاقه الفكر انهم
يتفقوا يتوافقون في تبني
وتصحيح كل ما قاله جهيمان والدفاع عنه لكن
يفرق طبعا في ذاك الوقت اللي لحقتنا عليه
على ابو هزاع عبد اللطيف الدرباسه كان همم
ابو محمد المقدسي يعني
الدرباس الدرباس ما كان يكفر الدوله
بكفر الدوار الحاكميه لانه كان يتبنى
الفكر الالباني لعدم
قضايا الايمان اما ال محمد المقدسي فكان
يكفر الدوله
للجمعه جهيمان
علاقه كويسه
واستمرت علاقتهم يعني
التنظيمات الحركيه في الكويت المؤثر
[موسيقى]
كانت هنا بعد بعد حادث جهيمان كانت الحركه
الفكريه
تزعمها الصحويه المساجد لكنها عن طريق
طريق ما يعني الطريق الطريق اللي يسمونه
السهل الممتنع في المساجد ما حد يعلم عنه
فيما بعد يعلم عنه اثرها فيما بعد اثره في
الشباب لكن الاثر ال- اللي فيه نزاع مع
الدول كان موجود
فكره المحاربه الدوله او الشجار مع الدوله
في السعوديه لكن لا زالت في الكويت موجوده
بسبب بسبب يعني اصول الفكريه الموجوده في
النظام السياسي في الكويت
فلا زالت موجوده فكانت فكانت تكلمون
وكانوا موجودين وبقايا الاخوان اللي
موجودين هناك
فانتعش هذا الفكر ثم القطبيين اللي كانوا
موجودين في الكويت
والخلطه اللي سواها ابو محمد المقدسي بين
الفكر القطبي وفكره الدعوه اخرج من
ابراهيم هذا هو السبب اللي جعله يشتهر
ومله ابراهيم وهي سبب اشتهاره ما اعرف
محمد الوقت ما اعرف يعني حتى بعد بعد كان
له رساله عن
[موسيقى]
عن منع الصبيان في المساجد لكنهما ما يعني
شهرت ابو محمد المقدسي من ابراهيم
بالنسبه لابو محمد المقدسي وعلاقته بجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين يعني
[موسيقى]
محمد سرور
من خلال سمعته انا في يوتيوب يتكلم انه
كان يجلس عند محمد سرور يوم كان في
الثانويه
مها بقايا جماعه جهيمان ومع التيارات
الاخرى انه كان ينتقد بشده مثلا
بعدين يعني صار في مفاصله بيننا وبين
جماعه الاخوان والتيار السروري او السلفيه
الاصلاحيه في الكويت
انه كان بكفر الليل كل من يدخل البرلمان
الكويتي الامه هذا من المسائل الفاصله
بيني وبين جماعه عبد الرحمن عبد الخالق في
جميع السلفيين جميع السلفيين هذه المسائل
اللي انا لحقت عليها وسمعتها سمعت
النقاشات يعني هذه سبب المفاصل مع
السلفيين اللي في الكويت
الحاكم لكن قبلها هي تكفير من يعني تكفير
كل من دخل البرنامج هذه مساله يعني كانت
خطير بالنسبه للسوريين كانت اشكاليه لانهم
موجودين فكان يحاربونه وكان الصراحه كان
يعني همم
كان محاربه السلفيين له اكثر من محاربه
الاخوان المسلمين
على
حسب تصنيفه
لكن كلهم متوجه هم اصلا
طبعا لكن هو معروفين في الكويت انه
الجماعه الخالق جماعه السلفيه السلفيين
الاصلاحيه اليهم جمعيه الاصلاح
هم بداوا يعني حتى بدا مع جماعه في
الستينات كسروا بعض الصور
لكن في الكويت كان اكثر
منها اكثر من يعني ضايقك كثير جماعه
عاهره
كانوا يكيدون هل كان في يعني جلسات نقاشيه
كانت في السعوديه بين محمد المقدسي وبين
مثلا فقط
موجود كان كان هناك نقاش بين همم
التراث
[موسيقى]
بقايا الاخوان اللي همم
حاول مساله
هل دخول الاخوان الحرم كانوا بتاويل سائق
ام منهم خوارج وظلال
التراث لم يكونوا يعذروا من دخل الحرم
وانه وانه ليس لهم تاويل فكان هذه بجانب
ومنهم الظاهر اذكر محمد ناصر العجمي
يعني حصلت اربع جلسات واذكرها جيدا وكان
حضرتك فيها يعني وقت امامها
وجهه نظر جماعه جهيمان عبد اللطيف الدربه
كان هو اللحام يبين لهم ان هناك يعني
تاويل وكان كثير من رؤوها الاخوان وهذا
بسبب هذا دخل الحرامي كان هذا النقاش حول
هذا وهذه جلسات كانت يعني
وكان من ضمنهم ايضا كان من ضمنه ابو ايوب
كان واحد اسمه ابو ايوب موجود
يعني فيما بعد سمعت انه ينتسب وهو كان
طبعا
موافق لابو محمد لكنهم جماعه تحرير
حزب التحرير لكنه كان ايضا على فكره محمد
ابو محمد المقدسي
فاااا يعني حصل النقاش حول هذا المساله
لكن يعني
ابو محمد كان ايضا يمثل
معلومه استاذ محمد اذا كان المقدسي
كما او بجماع بجهيمان قبل الاحتلال حرام
حتى لو عرفتني
وعمري 16 سنه
لكن هل
انتظم مع الاخوان الاخوان كلهم حركه قويه
في الكويت
ركز على المجتمع السعودي هل كان يحاول ان
يعني
كما هي مع المجتمع السعودي
والله هي خليط من الاسباب يعني هذا من
ضمنها لكنها اكثر يعني يمكن اخذ الاسباب
ان المجتمع السعودي يعني هو يعني
انه يركز على ان المجتمع السعودي ينتمي
للدوله
غير شرعيه
هذا اللي انا فهمت منه فلذلك لذلك
التركيز على تكفير الدوله واخراجها من
الشرعيه
يجعل يعني هذا في نظر بيجي على المجتمع
السعودي يتغير واذا تغيرت نظرته قد يكفر
الدوله واذا تكفر الدوله يعني يتسلسل
لكن هذه ما هذه صحيح
يعني له جذور في السعوديه قديمه
هو يقول ان انا اصلي من برا لكن ما
تحدث معك في هذا الموضوع وقتها ما كان
يطرح بالشده
وهي طبعا الرساله المقدسي استعاره من
رساله
للناس
وتعتبر هي رساله تنظيريه ومن اهمها
للجهيمان فهل تعتبر هذا الكتاب اللي ابو
محمد المقدسي انه حوالي على جماعه الجيمان
ويضع له مرجعيه في داخل السعوديه
هو تركيزك كان يعني هو هو في حديثه طبعا
في الكتابه يعني اشار اشارات بسيطه
للجهيمان لكنه في الحقيقه الكتاب مله
ابراهيم اكثر ارتكاجا
سيسه على ائمه الدعوه الجديده
لذلك يعني
اذا كان يقول مله ابراهيم تخصص اصلا فكره
لابو محمد يعني هو صحيح كان يعني يجعل
ولائه جهيمان ان ان يعني
بحكم ان جهيمان لم يكن موال للدول هذا هذا
هو هذا هو الجانب
العاطفي اللي ممكن تعاطف معهم لكنه فكريا
هو تعدى وتخطى في غير لانه يعتقد ان ان
حتى يعني
اعتقد انه جمال اخط ايضا في عدم تكفير
الدوله
[موسيقى]
الاول وبنتابع في الجزء الثاني حديث عن
ابو محمد المقدسي وابو نبدا من محطه مهمه
ذكرها ابو محمد المقدس بنفسها همم ما
عرفته باحد اللي نفذوا احد التفجيرات في
السعوديه وهو عبد العزيز مع السلامه
اه يعطيك العافيه استاذ محمد تابعونا في
الجزء الثاني هذا جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]